as soon as we got in the water all of a
sudden The Reef erupted in this glorious
display of light spots
it's for me the closest thing to Magic
that I've ever seen
on moonless nights in the Caribbean the
sea erupts in spectacular displays put
on by tiny Crustaceans called ostracods
in other parts of the world these
creatures only produce light to scare
off predators
but in the Caribbean male ostrocods spew
glowing mucus to attract females
when I started the work there were two
known species that emitted light in the
Caribbean
and now we have well over a hundred
that's just the tip of the iceberg we
can't keep up with descriptions because
we're discovering so many so fast
on the reefs we often find six or eight
different species one of my favorites is
Mara Stella Chico eye which does these
radiating displays then on the margin of
the coral is this downward displaying
species the very top of the reef you'll
get these slow upward displays and this
other one we call a rocket
you look at a firefly where the flashes
the Firefly still is an ostracon the
luminescence is in the past
you might see three or four or five or
more pulses and that's still not where
the male is individual pulses could last
for upwards of 10 seconds so you've got
100 milliseconds on one side or less and
then you've got 10 seconds on the other
side
as researchers continue to discover new
species advances in camera technology
since the early 2000s have allowed them
to better study these courtship displays
the recording capabilities that we had
were a generation 2 night vision device
it's just green right there's no actual
true color coming through to determine
quantitatively what's going on we would
then project those tapes onto a screen
and then we would laboriously map out
each display how long each pulse lasted
how far they were apart and so on
these days there are low light level
cameras all over the place most of our
workers now have these cameras and
they're able to get these videos and the
displays very easily with no fuss no
must
the way things have changed since I
started in 2001 to now has pretty much
made it that I could probably have done
my dissertation in a matter of months
rather than five years we got to work
with Martin Dorne where he created
What's called the beam splitter where we
could actually record with infrared on
one and then right in the same field of
view it would split and we could look at
the luminescence with a infrared filter
on top of it
being able to see ostrocods and their
bioluminescent signaling at the same
time helps scientists determine just how
many meals are present during courtship
displays there's an incredible amount of
competition and interactions that's
going on in complete darkness that we
don't even see until we could get the
infrared and especially when we got the
infrared going in the field sometimes
you can get upwards of 30 to 40 males
swarming the displaying mail
those males are trying to capture the
female before she can reach the one
that's displaying so we call them
sneakers
in addition to recording signaling
researchers also capture ostrocods to
study their anatomy and genetics this
helps them classify species and
understand their evolutionary history I
got really perplexed in Puerto Rico we
recorded different display types we saw
them in different habitats and every
time we collected them they looked
exactly the same
what we found is in Puerto Rico there
was this clade of one Genera that had
radiated into all these habitats and in
all these unique groups versus in other
places we find like all three or four of
the Genera that we often find there's
this this range that allows you so much
latitude in terms of looking at both
ecological diversification as well as
evolutionary diversification
major questions remain like why only
ostracod species in the Caribbean use
bioluminescence for signaling and how so
many species evolve to occupy different
parts of the environment
I want the world to know about them
right and hopefully maybe that would
help with conservation and an
appreciation of the environments that
we're at
[Music]